um for you like I know how big of a deal
it is to have Ghostface on the record
and have a relationship with Ghostface
and have them sit down in the cold on
your podcast like
I know that's a huge deal for you
um well then I tell you the Ghostface
versus some [__] vintage Ghost Face
[__] yes you did the verse is crazy
sounds like [__] Enter the 36
Chambers oh my God it's so good man like
I just think it's like I just think it's
dope to kind of just see like
your your grind like just paying off bro
nah absolutely and ghost he was just at
um we had a release party last Thursday
the night before dropped he was there he
pulled up pulled up yo super solid bro
super solid like he
like he's really tuned in too he's
tapped in with you know you see these
artists you grow up listening to these
people and you're just like
yo this [__] flying is crazy bro this
fight is mad aggressive yo busy if you
see the fly over there kill that
[__] bro
bro I need you to just take something
and hit it go give him a weapon give him
a hard Dean hat
give him the hard teen hat we need a
weapon I'm gonna kill this [__] sucking
fly this cockamani bastard it's right up
there it's on the other side of the
pillar oh you don't got no spray bro
what am I gonna [__] rate us out in
here we're in a small room you wanted me
to raid it right there yeah there you go
yeah just hit him with the [__] King
Palm tray bro
[__] ass fly got me [__] up 100 you
kill him with that
they used to give it to you no but you
were saying uh so Ghostface came to the
release party release pause yo he's just
super solid bro he's he's I gotta he's
like he's like around five or six all
the time for me in my personal list we
went through this [__] Supreme Clientele
one of the best hip-hop albums ever made
yeah I think if you like roll in like
Iron Man
obviously only Built for Cuban links in
his presence on that album he said on my
podcast he don't like Iron Man
he don't like the the his album Iron Man
could it could it be that do you think I
was gonna say I I somehow think liquid
sword somehow does it is like the most
somehow become the most underrated
Wu-Tang album ever because I feel like
it it always gets like [__] like yes
like trumped when people talk about like
only Built for Cuban links or 36
Chambers I'm like I don't know Liquid
Swords Liquid Swords is amazing I just
recently went back and listened to it
front to back so [__] good man
amazing album and it does you're
absolutely right I think that's also
because Giza is just very he's very
reserved yeah he's an introvert he
didn't have as big a personality as
absolutely as the other guys absolutely
that might be it too yeah I think that's
a lot of it too shout out to the Rizzo
man you ever tap in with a reason no I
met him recently
um but I never tapped them with them
like musically which it would be a dream
come true for sure absolutely I also
feel like he doesn't do a lot so be like
if you get a recipe exactly exactly what
are we doing here facts see that's like
like mugs like mugs
he posted I don't know it had to be a
year ago now but he posted one day like
yo I just found mad old dad tapes from
the 90s of my Beats whoa I hit him
immediately like yo
send me some Joy he sent me recently he
sent me like you're supposed you're
supposed to come on my show soon he's
got I'm coming out yeah yeah he's I
texted the guy back on my bucket of this
[__] please bring him by and I and we're
I think we're like neighbors because he
walks his dog on my street all the time
and I've never stopped and been like
yo mugs why because I just think it'd be
super weird bro mugs has an ill Mystique
about him bro in his studio is like in
our neighborhood so stupid it's in
Burbank because it looks like it because
I when we would just come here I was
like this mug Studio I could walk there
in like six minutes from my front door
okay it's just this black building next
to this popular Mexican restaurant and
it just the soul assassins A's on it and
I remember I hit my boy I'm like yo it's
mug studio in Burbank yeah it's right
there on Victory I was like yeah that's
crazy yeah legendary [__] and when you
go bro it's like a time machine in there
he got all like well once I interview
him I'm gonna try to I Wanna my goal is
to become friends so we can like walk
our dogs together
and then I can be like hey man can I
come and check the studio out yo that
that's that studio I recorded that last
time I was out here I was like bro this
[__] is like so you guys five Beats from
him from the dats from the dads the old
joints some of them are not even
complete but he's like yo if you [__]
with this I'll finish it up that's fire
I got you so have you uh tapped him with
Al yet Alchemist ow yo unheard story
right here unheard story nobody knows
this story
probably five six years ago
I [__] go to Al's crib
pick out a Beat
write it right there on the spot as I'm
writing the first verse
West Side gun comes in big body best is
already there
oh that's gotta be a cool hangover you
and big body best in the same place oh
my God yo [__]
[__] Conway comes in so I'm in I'm in
there's a center like the island in the
kitchen I'm writing it but these
[__] is having wild
conversations I got some other [__] on
my mind that just happened that same day
where I was like I really don't not in
the mood to write but I wrote These two
verses I put it on the beat
we did it after the next day both of us
hit each other was like um I think we
could do something better and I was like
yeah I think we could do something
better too yeah so let's just scrap it
and that's the only time I ever worked
The Alchemist and I'm so tight that that
happened because Alchemist is like one
of my favorites one of the girls
producers and I'm just it just was like
a [__] tornado of [__] that was going
on in my life and literally right there
while I was writing that just took me
off my game where I was just like we
could do better situation up yeah if you
and big body best are in the same place
is it like just like an aggravated
assault felony charge like in the air
absolutely just floating around
absolutely that same time I think the
next day me and him went drove to Vegas
together oh my God out to Vegas Vegas
with you two would be out because you're
sober now but like you're also you yeah
yeah facts I would just be like yo can
we go [__] with prostitutes like you
know my favorite thing to do in Vegas is
like because I used to live there
like you know I'd like just I'd like to
embarrass old men with their [__]
so like uh like I like walk up to like a
dude who's like with like you know
obvious prostitute you know like I'm
like GFE get the GFE going huh
girlfriend experience CFE for the hundo
100 roses
the back page those were the days 100
roses ah man
um what for you this album is all you
also have you I feel like you're a
pretty vulnerable guy in terms of like a
lot of people know a lot about like a
lot of low points in your life a lot of
you know your battles with addiction and
obviously being incarcerated but on this
album you kind of shared a little bit
about your family life yeah your Pops
passed away from AIDS yeah HIV yeah
contract he contracted HIV from Needles
needles yeah yeah yeah luckily me and my
moms didn't get it
um and yeah passed away when I was four
years old damn and that was probably I
mean I know you talk about kind of like
having a hard time forgiving him
yeah nah that was that was I said that
was gone okay okay my Pops I don't
really have that man I have like two
three memories about my father and one
of them is like etched in my mind it's
like like a movie scene now in my mind
when I think about it I remember walking
through the the funeral the the funeral
home my mother bringing me by the hand
and kissing them on his forehead in this
casket that's like one of the only
memories I have in my [__] yeah yeah
facts that's crazy so yeah yeah that
happens and you're kind of like forced
to like grow up and be like that'll be a
gotta be the man of the house from early
you know what I'm saying so it is what
it is these things make me who I am you
know yeah 100 man and like you know
adversity and like you said man like and
I'm not the only one that goes through
it so when you push it like that on song
there's nine billion people on this
Earth at least 900 million have gone
through the same exact thing or
something even similar not some people
that's what I'm saying that's like the
kind of [__] where like you put that
don't like a record and you're like oh
man this is gonna cut through to people
because you do like your [__] like where
you're talking about people having
um feminine benses you know what I'm
saying the C classes but then you also
if you have a record like that it's like
yo man I also like want y'all to like
really sit here with me and like you
know that's some [__] to live to bro I
mean why did why did why do we love
artists like you ain't get it no
why do we love artists like DMX why do
we love artists like Eminem because they
show the vulnerable side there's a
strength and vulnerability 100 you know
what I'm saying and and that those type
of songs and that type of music connects
with people on such a different level
and it becomes and it's Timeless right
right like I could rap about the
feminine bands and then smacking your
moms and punting your daughter but it's
cold for a minute it might wear out but
when you talk about real [__]
it's Timeless 100 percent